[Musica]
[Applauso]
Daniela
Daniele
È ora di andare Mi ha detto la mamma
Sì cacca ha aggiunto mio padre
hai compiuto 18 anni è arrivato il
momento in cui
deve abbandonare l'infanzia casa la
famiglia e scegliere la tua strada
Ma come era così bella questa infanzia
Ho imparato così tanto sono cresciuta
con i minatori della ruhr e loro mi
hanno insegnato
Quanto era difficile la loro mansione
e poi sono cresciuta con Camillo e papà
sulla Malga polinar
e Camillo mi ha insegnato a trasformare
il latte in formaggio casoletti in burro
e papà mi portava sulle cime al pascolo
per farmi
per insegnarmi quanto la natura è
Maestosa e quanto io dovevo apprendere
da lei osservandola
e poi poi Bettino Beppino che prendeva
dei Ceppi in legno e li trasformava in
piccole opere d'arte
E ho anche imparato
da Rinaldo e Bruno che per trasformare e
piegare il ferro lo dovevo scaldare
ero curiosa
poi c'era mamma un personaggio tedesca e
lei mi ha portato nella mondanità mi ha
fatto girare il mondo perché diceva che
dalla montagna Io potevo scoprire la
bellezza e poi era appassionata di moda
e poi mi ha fatto viaggiare proprio per
capire come tutte le persone al mondo
sono così diverse e quanto si può
imparare da loro
e se Size
ma era arrivato il momento in cui io
dovevo scegliere scegliere
il mio viaggio il mio viaggio vita
in realtà la vita l'avevo già ricevuta
da loro così questo tratto di tempo che
ognuno di noi ha a disposizione
nel quale può scegliere chi vuole essere
o cosa vuole essere e con questa vita io
avevo già ricevuto il mio DNA i miei
genitori mi avevano già dato la mia
essenza
Ah beh anche tutti i miei ricordi le mie
radici e anche il passato di tutto ciò
che era esistito prima di me c'era
dentro in questa vita
ma ora dovevo dovevo trovare come su
questa fune che si chiama vita
trovare il mio il mio nuovo equilibrio
equilibrio Ecco dovevo trovare la mia
sustain ability
e ero comunque curiosa e quindi
continuavo a chiedermi da cosa potevo
trovare l'ispirazione ed Osservando il
pianeta Ho imparato che la sua energia
interiore unita al suo al suo movimento
circolatorio erano equilibrio e la
stessa cosa
capivo anche osservando la natura lei
lei la mia grande maestra forse la
nostra grande maestra lei che comunque è
sempre in equilibrio Certo un equilibrio
statico perché le vicissitudini ci sono
cambiamenti ma lei ritrova il sempre il
suo equilibrio
e poi ci sono gli umani
e osservando impari l'equilibrio con gli
umani
ma dovevo partire da me il primo passo
da fare per cercare qual era il mio
viaggio era entrare dentro
a Daniela entrare dentro a me e non è
così facile Certo però
se tu togli tutto ciò che è superfluo se
tu se togliamo tutto ciò che ci distrae
entriamo invece nella parte più profonda
di noi stessa quella della nostra
essenza Ecco che stiamo bene con noi e
quindi trovi te stessa
e
trovi anche l'equilibrio tra il conscio
e l'inconscio quindi tra il nostro
sentire e la nostra razionalità e la
ragione e quando trovi questo equilibrio
Ecco Stai bene in quel momento mi viene
da urlare il pinguino
Perché Perché noi siamo all'essenza e se
noi continuiamo a rimanere ciò che noi
siamo saremo sempre e staremo bene e
Ecco adesso era giunto il momento in cui
dovevo decidere
Qual era la mia mansione qual era il mio
viaggio e che cosa di più semplice che
chiedercelo entrando nella nostra
essenza e ho riscoperto E ho scoperto
ancora una volta che la mia curiosità il
mio piacere deve avere la materia nelle
mani e di trasformarla era veramente ciò
che mi faceva stare bene E così
potevo dire Ok ma io ora esisto e prendo
il mio viaggio e quindi inizia a creare
che cosa creo Dove posso attingere cosa
di più facile che attingere
in quello che avevi imparato
guardandoti dietro io sono cresciuto in
una famiglia dove dove si parlava di
moda
e dove si trasformavano
tessuti investiti e quindi
era quello il mio vento Perfetto io
dovevo vestire un corpo
vestire un corpo la mia mansione in
realtà come si fa a vestire un corpo
la materia nelle mani Questa è la prima
cosa grande conoscenza tecnologica senza
razionalità e senza preparazione non si
può creare Ma poi si aggiunge la
fantasia la fantasia di unire tessuti
materie e di creare ciò che ancora non
hai visto ciò che non avevi mai toccato
e forse l'esempio migliore è quello se
io vi racconto come creo forse tipo
prendiamo Ecco prendiamo le parole
di uno scrittore uno scrittore vuole
scrivere la sua storia Lui ha già le sue
immaginario esattamente
scritta la storia che vorrebbe lasciare
a trasmettere ma è la sequenza delle
parole che poi permettono agli altri di
capire la storia e la stessa cosa è
quando si crea un vestito si inizia a
tagliare Assieme a Maria lo cucio lo
unisco e poi vado in un altro reparto e
comincio a trattarlo ad appoggiare
ricami appoggiare materia e poi quando
scorre sotto alla macchina da cucire
Ecco seguire il tratto di una macchina
da cucire ma con fantasia senza mai
sentirsi
legati sempre solo con l'immaginazione
ho cominciato
vestendo donne
e la
prima cosa che volevo fare era avere
rispetto per loro faccio un esempio
ho deciso che tutti i vestiti che creavo
dovevano essere rispetto per il loro
ritmi perché oggi i nostri ritmi sono
frenetici e quindi tutto lavabile ad
acqua questo per me era il rispetto per
una donna in modo che lei possa occupare
tempo per le altre per le altre sue
passioni e il mio compito era quello di
diventare
la persona che crea il vestito che è lo
specchio dell'anima di quella persona
Dove si prendono le idee in tutto ciò
che hai raccolto nella vita in tutto
quello che io avevo scoperto viaggiando
osservando
Ma
quando crei e quando io creo i vestiti
provo
un tale piacere sento l'energia che si
moltiplica io lo chiamo quel
solletichino dentro di me che mi fa
sentire bene e così ho aggiunto anche
Ecco ho deciso che volevo anche vestire
gli ambienti gli spazi per poter
continuare a creare e anche creare
elementi per uno spazio e altrettanto
stimolante perché come sempre serve
grande conoscenza ma sono anche momenti
di condivisione
con chi tocca insieme a te e trasforma
il vetro in legno il cemento in oggetti
lo spazio molto spesso si crede che
riempire uno spazio di elementi
significhi appoggiarli tutto intorno sui
confini Io invece
amo lasciare agli elementi di arredo la
libertà di stare All'interno dello
spazio dove vogliono Ecco perché li creo
bellissime a 360 gradi non hanno una
facciata un armadio non ha una facciata
ma lo guardo tutti i suoi aspetti e
su ruote
assemblando materiali
con tecnologie nuove quindi senza
razionalità e senza tecnologia non si
può creare ma serve sempre la fantasia
la fantasia Da che parte da una totale
libertà interiore
e poi ho sentito il bisogno di avere un
luogo dove appoggiare E così ho deciso
di creare la baracca sul mare
la baracca sul mare Innanzitutto doveva
essere
ecologica perché non c'è cosa più
importante che il rispetto e rispetto
per la natura e per il nostro pianeta
Terra
E certo quando tu crei un edificio entra
in gioco la assolutamente la razionalità
la matematica e quindi la baracca sul
mare doveva essere in assoluto
rispetto Ecco che
240 pali di fondazione per l'antisismica
e non poteva essere diverso ma nello
stesso tempo anche 45 sonde
geotermiche a 120 metri sotto la terra
la per andare a prendere l'energia certo
domotica senza domotica non si deve non
si può creare un ambiente ma doveva
anche essere fotovoltaico perché io amo
rispettare la terra la mia infanzia Mi
aveva insegnato quello
Near Zero Energy building assolutamente
solo così io potevo creare uno spazio
per fare cosa che in questo spazio
sicuramente per appoggiare per
appoggiare la creatività per appoggiare
ciò che mi faceva stare bene mi fa stare
bene ma anche per incontrare per
incontrare le persone per la
condivisione
per parlare
di quanto è bello avere rispetto per il
pianeta per la materia e anche
per sentirsi in equilibrio in equilibrio
assieme agli altri certo per fare
impresa per portare nel mondo la
bellezza
di tutto ciò che in Italia noi facciamo
e per portare la creatività
Perché da quella mondanità da
quell'infanzia avevo attinto
alla bellezza
e quando senti la bellezza dentro di te
e la vuoi trasformare Ecco Avevo trovato
la mia mansione E quando tu trovi la tua
mansione ecco
questo è e a piedi scalzi
per mantenere il rapporto con la terra
per mantenere il rapporto con la
concretezza per rispettare il pianeta
Però
ad ali aperte perché
con l'immaginazione con la fantasia puoi
guardare lontano poi guardare nel futuro
e continuare a rispettare questo per me
equilibrio
questo per me e se stai in ability
[Applauso]